entrée dans la cour du château de
saint-germain-en-laye avec le rythme de
la batucada brésilienne et se laisser
guider par les ombres et lumières
c'était la proposition réussite du musée
d'archéologie nationale de la ville pour
la nuit des musées 2022 plusieurs
animations étaient au programme avec un
accent cette année sur le célèbre
dramaturge molière le château abrite
comme ce que vous pouvez entendre
derrière moi deux magnifiques cnet un
cri ont été réinterprétés par une troupe
de comédiens grâce au théâtre alexandre
dumas c'est un partenariat qui nous
permet de faire revivre quelque part
c'est comédie créée directement au
château de saint germain va présenter
monsieur de pourceaugnac qui est une
comédie ballet après on a présenté les
fourberies de scapin ensuite la jalousie
du barbouillé une petite farce en un
acte et on a fini avec
le malade imaginaire de ces soirées
comme ça un petit peu avec de la magie
dans l'air et puis de l'énergie qui nous
est donné par ses acteurs ses
fantastiques et molière quelle modernité
ça redonne envie de
redécouvrir monial incroyable un
extérieur festif qui mène à la visite du
musée d'archéologie nationale depuis
plusieurs éditions des médiateurs
étudiants en partenariat avec
l'université paris dauphine et l'école
du louvre sont présents dans chaque
salle pour guider le public l'occasion
pour les petits comme pour les plus
grands de découvrir autrement les lieux
c'est aussi une expérience pour nous
d'apprendre à présenter en fait des
vestiges archéologiques que même nous
fortement n'est pas de tension
spécialiste dans la matière c'est pas
vraiment notre domaine d'action
prioritaire du pont on apprend en fait
ce soir on n'a pas affaire à des
spécialistes de l'archéologie mais
vraiment à des étudiants qui a envie de
partager un moment avec les gens qui
déambulent dans les espaces est donc
partagée aussi leurs coups de coeur dans
ses différents espaces très intéressante
et enrichissante c'est à des guides dans
tous les ans toutes les salles
c'est encore plus prenant et comprend
c'est pour nous le chaton a été bâti à
l'onf a été construit par rapport à la
chapelle qui était déjà existante depuis
des siècles et des siècles et ça ça nous
fait découvrir vraiment l'histoire
de la france dans un cadre idyllique et
avec la magie de la tombée de la nuit la
nuit des musées au musée d'archéologie
nationale est un événement qui attire
chaque année son public près de 2500
personnes ont répondu présent ce soir là